welcome to hari sadhus the channel where
we discussed the latest tech news and
delve into newest tech products today
we're taking a look at how the 12
nanometer architecture and GTD are six
memory will affect the gtx 1180 pic is
on paper the technical specifications of
the gtx 1180 seem to be identical or
very similar with the gtx 980ti
but before we get into that make sure to
hit that subscribe button if you guys
would like to stay updated with the
latest techniques related gaming and pcs
so what happened well recently micron
released the official specs for their
new gddr3 they've posted a huge 22 page
document with all the specific details
about the GDD or six memory but the most
important and the most significant
upgrade is definitely that the data
array is going to now be sixteen
gigabytes a second so previously gddr5
memory had a data transfer rate of 8
gigabytes per second and gddr5 X memory
had a transfer rate of Qom gigabytes per
second so that's twice as fast as gddr5
memory and one and a half times the
speed of gddr5 X memory so it is quite
significant what's even more surprising
is that micron claims that they can
overclock this new memory all the way up
to 20 gigabytes per second if they make
some slight modifications now does that
mean that we will see 20 gigabytes per
second on G DDR 6 memory well
unfortunately probably not however that
may be what we will get with GD are 6 X
memory or whatever the next upgrade is
so what exactly does this mean for
graphics cards however well if you take
the GTX 280s gddr5 X memory and swap it
out with the hopeful GDR 6 X memory with
20 gigabytes per second speed and you
keep the 256-bit memory interface with
then the memory bandwidth of the GT x
1080 would go from just 320 gigabytes
per second all the way to 640 gigabytes
per second which is very close to the
Titan beast memory bandwidth of 652
point 8 gigabytes per
second so that's all cool and all but
what real world performance does is
actually translate into well
unfortunately this new GDR six memory
isn't going to double the speed or
anything and a more reasonable estimate
would be more or less 10 frames per
second for the GTX 1180 and 1180 TI
whose predecessors already had gddr5 X
memory so it's less of an upgrade for
those cards so for example if you take
the gtx 980ti
and the gtx 1180 right now the specs
seem identical except for the fact that
the gtx 1180 will have GD d r 6 memory
and 12 millimeter architecture the GDD r
6 memory portion of the upgrade may lead
to an increase of 10 frames per second
more or less but that's pretty much it
due to GD d r 6 memory for lower-level
cards like the gtx 1160 and 1150 and
1170 the upgrade may be more significant
because those predecessors only had
gddr5 memory whose memory speed was half
so for those we may be seeing a FPS
increase of maybe 15 to 20 but even that
is a bit hopeful so really this will
probably offer more or less 10 FPS so
should you wait well as for the gtx
1080i all you guys who are considering
to buy that card the gtx 1180 specs look
pretty much identical if you guys want
the full rundown on all the numbers and
things like that
- make sure to check out my full
dedicated video on the gtx 1180 but
overall the only thing that seems to be
differentiating the gtx 980ti and the
gtx 1180 is the GDD r6 memory 12
millimeter architecture and a bit better
efficiency so as I suggested before the
GDD r6 memory may lead to an increase of
10 frames per second and then 12
nanometers architecture along with the
extra overclocking Headroom provided by
the extra efficiency may lead to an
additional 10 frames per second so I
think we can expect around 10 to 20
frames per second extra from the gtx
1180 on over the gtx 980ti so taking
that into consideration
it may be worth waiting for the gtx 1180
if you guys want a little extra
performance or would like to be on the
newest architecture however the
performance difference is quite minimal
see if you guys find a really good deal
on the GTX 10 atti then it may be better
just to go ahead and buy that instead if
you don't really care about the extra
performance or being on the newest
architecture of the gtx 1180 and you
guys just want to buy a gtx 1080i then
something else to consider is that the
gtx 980ti
will dropped in price most likely once
the gtx 1180 comes out so once the gtx
1180 comes out you may be able to find
really good discounts and deals for the
gtx 980ti so it may be worth waiting for
the gtx 1180 to come out before buying a
gtx 980ti even if you know that the gtx
980ti is what you want ask for lower
level graphics cards the story is a lot
different base we are comparing the same
level of GPU for example we would be
comparing a 1060 with 1160 if you didn't
notice already we were comparing 1180
and a 1080 Ti not 1180 I and a 1080 Ti
the 1180 Ti is not coming out for over a
year from now so it really doesn't make
sense to compare those two and so as a
result for lower level cards we can
compare the same level of GPUs and so
the story is a lot different for these
cards like the 1150 1160 and 1170 these
cards are not only getting the
improvement from the GDD r6 memory and
12 nanometer architecture but they are
also getting a technical specification
upgrade as well for example we will
probably see an upgrade in cuda cores
and TM use across the board for all
those GPUs and on top of that those cars
should pretty much cost the same as what
you are going to spend on the 10 series
right now so those are definitely worth
considering to wait for as for the 11
series I think we can safely assume that
the 11th series will provide over a
single GPU level of upgrade over the
predecessor so for example the GTX 1160
should perform a little bit better than
the gtx 1070 and the gtx 1170 should
barely perform better than the GTA
ten eighty and so on and so forth based
on how the gtx 1180 just does it barely
better than a gtx 980ti so pretty much
for the price that you are willing to
spend on a gtx 1060 right now you can
get the performance of politico's better
than the gtx 1070 so i really recommend
that you guys consider waiting if you
can but that's pretty much it for the
gtx 980ti it doesn't really make sense
for waiting because the next biggest
competitor that is coming for it is that
gtx 1180
and that should pretty much offer the
same performance as the gtx 1080i so it
doesn't really matter if you wait for it
or not but for all the other cards I
definitely recommend you guys wait for
it because the performance upgrade will
be quite significant but that's just my
opinion
what do you guys think are you guys
excited for GT dr6 memory and what do
you think about the new it called
nanometer architecture and the 1100
series make sure to comment down below
what you guys think because I do read
all my comments and I'm curious as to
what you guys think so make sure to post
your thoughts also if you guys like this
video then make sure drop a like and hit
that subscribe button if you guys would
like to see more videos just like this
one but until next time bye
[Music]